there's a couple different ways to
approach this one way to do this is to
make a table in terms of the time okay
so if T you could think of as like time
and the X is really the horizontal
direction the Y is the vertical
direction and what we're doing is we're
splitting those equations into into two
parts and basically as you can see as
time is increasing we want to see what
happens to say for example the position
of this particle or object right so
let's just take like an example so if
say for example we put 0 in for T we get
0 minus 1 is negative 1 but if we put 0
in for T into the second equation we're
getting 2 times 0 0 plus 1 is 1 okay and
if we put 1 in 1 minus 1 is 0 let's see
2 minus 1 is 1 3 minus 1 is 2 and 4
minus 1 is 3 and then for y let's see if
we put in one we're getting 2 plus 1 is
3 2 times 2 is 4 plus 1 is 5 2 times 3
is 6 plus 1 is 7 and 9 right ok so now
what we're gonna do is were going to
plot these points okay on our coordinate
axis and you can see negative 1 1 okay
this is going to be right here 0 3
that's going to be right here a 1 5
that's going to be right here
2 7 is kind of going off for graph a
little bit like that so now when you
when you graph these parametric curves
we're so used to when we draw like for
example a graph we put like arrows to
show that it like keeps going in both
directions you don't actually do that
with parametric graphs you just draw the
the curve or the line or whatever the
shape of the graph is and then what you
want to do is you want to draw Direction
arrows and what that means is that with
increasing values of T which direction
is this object going so you can see us T
is increasing I was plotting my points
going up to the right like this so what
I would do is I would just draw some
arrows indicating the direction that the
object is traveling now the other way
okay so this one I think what we're
going to do is we're going to jump right
in to eliminating the parameter first
okay as opposed to maybe making a table
first so the one thing that I want you
to remember is the Pythagorean trig
identity so remember Pythagorean trig
identity looks like this right sine
squared plus cosine squared equals 1
so what we're going to do now is we're
going to rewrite these two equations
solving for cosine or sine so if we do
that here you can see cosine of theta
equals x divided by two just dividing
both sides by two and what we can do
then is substitute that in place of
cosine here so that's x over two squared
because cosine is squared this one we're
going to add one and divide by three so
this is actually y plus one divided by
three equals sine theta so we're going
to put that in here so that's y plus one
over three squared okay and that equals
one so now you can see what we've done
is we've eliminated the parameter we've
got everything in terms of just X's and
Y's we've got rid of the theta and if we
simplify a little bit further here what
you can see is this is going to be I'm
going to rewrite this a little bit
additions commutative someone to write
this as x squared over four this one I'm
gonna write as one y plus one squared
over 9 equals one now does anyone
recognize the equation the graph that
this equation represents well you can
see that it's a ellipse right an ellipse
and the center of the ellipse over here
is going to be at zero negative one so
that's going to be zero down one and you
can see we're going to in the X
Direction square root of four is two
we're going three in the Y direction
okay one two three see one two three and
one two three so now you can see that
this is an ellipse okay a little bit
more elongated in the vertical direction
in the Y direction but now let's go
ahead and get an idea which way is this
particle or object traveling with
increasing values of theta so let's put
in zero so we put in zero what do we get
well we get cosine of zero is one right
from our unit circle times two which is
two okay and then say for example put in
ninety what's the cosine of 90 at zero
times two is still 0 and then for y
let's say we put in zero sine of 0 is 0
times 3 is 0 minus one is negative one
and if we put in 90 the sine of 90 we
know is one times three is three minus
one is two ok so now if we plot these
points you can see we're starting at
two negative one that's this point right
here and then as theta goes to 90
degrees we're going to be at the point
zero two that's this point here so you
can see us theta is getting larger and
larger we're going in this
counterclockwise direction so that's our
graph it's an ellipse but what's
interesting about the parametric
equations again is that we have an
orientation we have a direction with
increasing values of our parameter in
this case the parameter was theta and
these other two examples our parameter
was T perhaps T stands for time and so
that's a brief overview of how to solve
and graph some of these parametric
equations I hope you liked the video
subscribe to the channel check out more
math tutoring videos on my youtube
channel Mario's math tutoring and I look
forward to helping you in the future
videos I'll talk to you soon